[Music]
gals dating fat guys so you've all seen
something like this right where it's a
fat older dude with a hot gal
it's very simply explained women
prioritize resources
in men especially over a long term basis
and
men don't you know men prioritize Beauty
because when men look at women they're
looking at somebody that has hips that
can child bear that's beautiful that's
youthful that's fertile uh you know
things like that the Optics of beauty
are more important than success and
wealth whereas for women
he's not
carrying the child for nine months dudes
don't do that I know that we live in a
new new age woke world where there's new
narratives that are that are being sold
and they want people drunk on that
Kool-Aid and you guys can figure that
out for yourselves you know hopefully
you do shouldn't have to be explained to
you but you know men are success objects
they always have been and they always
will be and that's just the way it
happens to be and I don't see that
changing anytime soon so when it comes
to hot women dating less than ideal men
or guys that are viewed upon as less
than ideal by you know the average Joe
out there it's it's because they're
loaded you know they're they're the
they're the president of formula one
they're uh CEO of of something other
they've got multiple boats and planes
and stuff like this I've actually got a
video
um I had to watch the um edit the other
day uh because my editors sent it over
to me with a new thumbnail so I so I
always watch them through before they
get published on the entrepreneurs and
cars Channel and uh if you don't know
um who Saudia Khan is there's a clip
that's going to be inserted into that
one she's this uh she's this Pakistani
lady with an English accent that's been
doing the podcast rounds and there's a
clip that that she's been made famous
for about talking about how uh Rich
wealthy guys get cheated on more than
average dudes which is also interesting
um
and there's some dynamics that are
missing
um in that I mean it's great to make the
statement but to fill in the holes and
explain why it happens is what I tend to
like doing and you'll see that come out
probably maybe tomorrow or on uh like
let's just say Wednesday or Thursday
this week but you'll see this week for
sure
um explain in Greater detail so I want
to move on to the more disabled sort of
stuff
um
so let me just pull this out of the
screen remove
um
there's this there's this Dynamic which
I find interesting and I first came
across it myself personally
um I don't know it was December of 2010
I think it was let me just I'm sort of
scrolling down here on my Facebook
photos because I have a image from the
event I was at a Costa Rica at this gig
and there's this guy Sean Stevenson I've
talked about him before here he is
I've talked about them before
let me share that up on the screen stop
screen
and share
is that it there it is so
here I'll just go blur your screen so
you can see so this dude over here
um I've had him on a podcast on my
channel yes that's me younger fella
without a beard of course
um I've had him on a podcast on my
channel he died a couple years ago I
think he um he fell out of his chair or
something but either way he made it to
40. he wasn't expected to live that long
he was about three feet tall he got lots
and lots of media coverage for what he
did he was he was a clinical
psychologist and very well spoken dude
and there's a picture of his girlfriend
here somewhere this here it is this is
her over here I think she's not a big uh
chick so she's not tall but she's not a
I think what's classified as a I
think you have to be under like three
three or four feet or something like
that she's probably about four foot
eight she wasn't a tall woman
um but a pretty girl right and
they were
um a couple you know and you know some
people might have thought well that's
unusual you know why does that happen
how did that happen sort of thing and
um you know it just it just happened to
happen I think because the guy was so
successful uh Sean Sean Stevenson he had
some degenerative bone disease that that
would essentially his bones would break
for no reason he would sneeze he would
roll over the wrong way when he was
sleeping something like that but you
definitely have to go back to the plain
and wood podcast I did with Sean he's an
amazing dude has such great Insight it's
one of my favorite podcasts that I've
ever done so just go to entrepreneurs
and cars and put entrepreneurs in cars
uh Sean Stevenson and it'll pop up it's
one of the last interviews he did before
he had his accident in uh passed uh okay
so four foot eight and under apparently
is considered a dwarf so I think Mindy
is just is definitely under five foot
but she wasn't considered like she
didn't have dwarfism like the uh
category of uh let me put her up on the
screen over here see can get a closer
look at Sean's ex because I think they
got married too if I'm not mistaken so
this is her over here cute girl
um
this is them together I guess after
um you know they had gotten married and
some people might question okay well you
know he's less than ideal or you know
whatever it happened to be
um but they were very closely related
they were very closely closely aligned
um it was legit like when I saw them in
person and I'm stating this because I
met them and I spent several days around
them at that conference it was legit she
looked up to him uh she saw him as the
best that she could do and to be honest
with you um I think it was three three
or four years ago now that he passed it
was definitely before 2019 it was
definitely before the whole scandemic
thing and she is from what I can see
under social media she hasn't replaced
him okay I don't see any other dude
there I don't see any dating pictures no
new relationships or anything like that
it's just old pictures of her and him so
she's a widow so it can legit happen now
the squirmyian grubs one I found
interesting now if you don't know who
squirmy and grubs is I'll throw up the
YouTube channel uh here
um some people may not have heard of
them
been asked a lot about this this this
couple here
um he's disabled I'm not sure what his
issue is uh but he's a small guy it's
it's not Sean's uh disease he's he's
um he doesn't have broken bones it
doesn't look like uh but she is
objectively a very attractive woman
their most recent videos are talking
about doing IVF
um our final IVF results is this one
they do q a segments
um
that's sort of like the podcast sort of
version of their show it doesn't look
like they do vlogs anymore it seemed
like they they were big about doing
Vlogs but it's like back and forth stuff
like this so these are the most recent
videos on the feet you see them sitting
down in these chairs with microphones
just shooting the sort of thing and
let me throw up their Instagram so you
can get a little more of a visual of
their day-to-day lives uh presents share
screen
her name's Hannah and it looks like
she's now married because she's taken on
his last name his last name is burkha
and um this is her feet it's it's mostly
them together right
um with the exception of this one bikini
picture over here where it's just her
um but you know like you can see she's
objectively a very attractive woman so
guys have been asking me questions like
why do you think this is going down like
what's going on here with the dynamic
Rich you know like what's up
um
I have questions about this one
Sean and Mindy I didn't it was obvious
to me anyway that it was legit and it
seems obvious in hindsight since she's
been widowed and she hasn't taken on a
new guy in her life and she's continued
sort of on his mission and whenever you
see a video with her talking about it
she fondly reminisces about him and
obviously has a place in her heart for
this guy this one
honestly I don't know I really don't
know the strange thing about the whole
um situation here with uh Hannah burka
and uh where Shane's Graham here let me
put that up as well so you can see that
one
so the strange thing about this one is
this guy has managed to pull
a hot chick like I said you know she
she's objectively attractive as a woman
would go I don't think many guys would
argue be like oh she's gross I think the
vast majority of guys would just look at
that and be like she's pretty hot like
if you saw in a dating app you'd
probably swipe right right
um I don't know that guys in in a
condition like this would get the same
reaction form you know from women on the
dating app but this this dude over here
has managed to pull not one hot women
but three from what I could find uh
objectively attractive women all very
similar looking now when you start sort
of going through
um yeah not in the chat average
friendship Watcher she's a four yeah
exactly
um but when you start going through some
of the videos that you find online
talking about this couple they're not
really uh yeah
me too uh actually they're not
um they're not found out in a positive
light it seems like most of the stuff
that you see from other channels on them
it's like exposed scam it's all a game
and then they start going through
interviews which is what typically
happens on YouTube because now you have
a public life and they can go through
all your older videos and stuff and
they're like oh you know he said this
about this girlfriend and then this
about this this girlfriend and they said
that they didn't do it for views or
YouTube or the money but here's a
YouTube channel and talk of money prior
to this conversation so some things
don't line up if this is fake this has
got to be one of the biggest scams on
YouTube right now on social media in
that in that space if it's fake uh
because they honest like if it's fake
they're doing a really good job like
they've gone to the point where they've
gotten married they've been making
videos for years
um they're going through IVF right now
again you know this is the gal over here
she's objectively
what you would call very attractive
right and she's you know like this is
her job she pours a glass for herself
and she you know she gives it to this
guy over here
um you know awesome you know we're on a
looks like a flight somewhere
um you know they're doing real well
together you know as far as this squirmy
grubs project and getting attention and
uh podcasts and Views and interviews and
all this like all the they put on
is buggy
and she's okay well that's a little bit
interesting
just just watch for to the end the last
video slide
she's skipping along with her bag and
all the shits on his buggy yeah okay
that that starts to raise some questions
I mean look
if you had to place a bet most guys that
would see something like this
you know they would they would be like
okay that's that's a game you know like
they would they're they're probably the
kind of people that bet the farm and be
like let's see you know what happens
when the truth is revealed because
light is going to disinfect everything
over time you know
one of the things I learned from lawyers
you know dealing with lawsuits and
anything in uh business is they've
always told me the truth always has a
way of revealing itself to you as time
goes on
if again this is a scam and it's a play
it is one of the best ones I've ever
seen
I honestly can't tell you the truth it's
it's very very confusing I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're newer to the channel make sure
you hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out